even an increasingly deadly State
Crackdown hasn't stopped them Iranians
across the country keep calling for the
toppling of Ayatollah they told him
responsible for the death of Masha amini
many people targeted by the Islamic
Republic's Security Forces avoid
treatment in hospitals for fear of being
arrested instead help comes from 10 000
kilometers away Dr kaiben mihani and
iranian-american doctor is chief of
internal medicine at the Clifton Springs
Hospital in New York he offers medical
advice online Dr Mahari thank you so
much for making time for Deutsche well
so maybe you can walk us through how
this works so people send you pictures
of their injuries and how do you con how
do you get in contact with them how do
you answer their questions I've
developed a system where you know I tell
my followers to put SOS in their
messages because to get a lot of
different other messages coming in then
I triage the ones that are the most sick
and in need of care I figure out I ask
them where they live
mind you some some of the messages seem
very suspicious almost
um they're fishing for more information
or doctors that are willing to
participate so I have to differentiate
between the message that's real and
those that I feel like they're coming
from fake accounts so I have to review
their account information I have to see
if they have messaged me before the last
three years in my page about my children
or other things then I know it's a
reliable source I look at their injury
if I can help them over Instagram
sometimes I ask for images of their leg
or their arms I look at it to the best
of my ability I tell them what to do if
I can guide them towards going to the
hospital with a different story I will
teach them how to do that you know say I
am a kickboxer and I got hit in the head
and now this is going on so sometimes I
guide them towards getting care in the
hospital then I have a team of doctors
that I've built a relationship with over
the last three years during covet and I
feel like they're safe and then I
connect the two my wife is also involved
she's the social worker so she's very
good at making the connection
and a lot of them go and see the doctor
a lot most of the time it's Secret in
secrecy they have to actually say
certain words and sentences to be able
to see that that doctor and I've learned
those two are from the doctors that I'm
they're my colleagues in Iran like they
have to say Mr whatever referred me to
you for this it might be like a weight
loss clinic that are actually taking out
sutures or they're taking out pallets so
the situation is very convoluted
um but I guess I just you know the
easiest example I can give you is like
that
so and maybe you can talk a little bit
about the most common injuries you're
seeing the most common are
um wounds from pellets
um they can be from bird shots majority
are bird shots because they're multiple
anywhere from 20 pellets to 50 to 100
and now I'm seeing injuries with a paint
gun where the actual bullet is metal
it's not from a pinch so I'm staying I'm
seeing a larger wound with necrotic
surrounding they don't penetrate inside
the body but again if they don't take
care of that wound it can become
infected and they can be septic but the
pellets are actually penetrating where
they can severe arteries and it can
cause damage to the nerves if they're in
a joint they have to be operated on so
my job is kind of triaging like who
really needs to go see an orthopedic
surgeon who really needs to go to the ER
how dangerous the these gunshot wounds
are I'm also seeing a lot of second and
third degree burns from electrical
batons that they're using a lot of these
Burns need medical attention like IV
antibiotics IV fluids large bruises
throughout their body from fighting with
the police or falling down while they're
running away these can turn into
compartment syndrome plantar fasciae
necrotizing fasciitis these are very
life-threatening conditions where
sometimes I get an image three days
later I get a follow-up image that I say
oh no you have to go see a surgeon right
now let me find you one but the
conditions where they're operating on
these individuals are sub-optimal
they're not the normal conditions you
would see in in our countries here how
is the supply situation in in hospitals
in Iran I'm glad you asked that it's the
first time I've been asked that question
it's uh very scarce
um medication especially antibiotics
because of this situation a lot of
people are getting shot but so they have
to take prophylactic antibiotics I just
found out the other day that many
pharmacies do not have enough supplies
to give to people so a lot of people are
just using maybe home remedies or
putting honey in their wounds for
healing
um and in terms of whether they need
surgical procedures a lot of them are
using tweezers that they're disinfecting
over the candle fire and just using that
they're not using actual surgical
instruments if they end up going to a
clinic that's private and safe they may
they will get decent care of their
wounds but again my biggest fear is the
low supply of antibiotics and also
tetanus vaccine because a lot of these
individuals would need tetanus boosters
and they're running low on that too
you've been offering medical advice
online now for weeks is the situation
getting worse how would you describe it
I think it's as bad as it was three
weeks ago I continuously get questions
about injuries I'm not seeing a decrease
in the number of number of SOS messages
that I get on my Instagram
that's why I'm kind of reaching out to
the community outside of Iran for for
help and I I do feel hopeless at some
points because I cannot keep up with all
these messages how many messages do you
get doctor
um I extrapolated based on an hourly
message close to 300 to 500 messages a
day every 24 hours what is your main
Channel you you get these images
it's Instagram my page
um Dr K which um I I started the page
three years ago when covet started so it
gained a significant popularity in Iran
I think it has become their number
source of medical information right now
what about uh internet censorship is it
difficult uh for your patients in Iran
to contact you via Instagram and other
social media platforms uh yeah there's
times where I don't receive any messages
and I know there's some sort of
censorship or block going on on the
internet sometimes there's a delay where
somebody is at a friend's house bleeding
out of their leg and they're waiting to
send that message to me uh just imagine
that you're responsible for helping
somebody many many thousands of miles
away and you're not even able to receive
their message like they're sending an
image of somebody I had a patient that
got shot in the eye but the mess the
picture was not coming to me because how
slow the internet was
so even from like a technological
standpoint making the connection of
trying to get help is getting more
difficult so you know they're just it's
just getting very hard for them to take
care of themselves that brings me to my
question doctor what could the
International Community uh do to help
people in Iran protesters in Iran I feel
hopeless you know I unless these
something happens that you know they're
able to go get go to the hospital go see
their doctors I feel like you know
um I see no light down the tunnel to be
honest with you but I do have a lot of
other doctors a lot of nurses inside
Iran outside of Iran all trying to help
and that's really what gets me going you
know the unity that Iranian people have
to help each other what keeps them going
I don't know I talk I talk to a lot of
my Iranian people and they feel like
this time it's different it there is a
and uh there's a Unity you know in all
of Iran and outside of Iran I don't know
if um if you saw 50 000 people came out
in Toronto just in support of what's
going on in Iran they feel that Unity I
I've a lot of my messages are There's
Hope in them even though what's what's
happening I have
um I I just had a young girl last week
who went out you know there was the
Takeover of the sheriff University and
she was one of the ones that went to
make a commotion so that they let the
students go she came back to me sent a
picture of her nose and said oh they
broke my nose and I was I felt so sad I
said I'm sorry to
put the story so that you go and get
hurt she's like no problem I will give
my whole body for what's going on I'll
go back again tomorrow as long as you
say it's okay if the bleeding stops I'm
gonna go and protest again so I think
it's the new generation it's the unity
that they have they just they want
change it's different it's definitely
different thank you so very much for
this conversation and I wish you
strengths and um maybe we can catch up
at some point thank you sir for sure
thank you so much thank you